hey guys how's it going happy tech
Tuesday today we're going to be unboxing
Apple watch bands almost all of the new
ones that they announced fairly recently
the Apple town hall event I say almost
all because some of the nylon bands were
very similar I almost feel like they
kind of released way too many colors of
a very similar color palette first off I
want to open the Milanese loop this is
the black version of the Milanese loop
it's super sleek it's beautiful it's
just a real beautiful piece of metal
alright so you just got to loop these on
this has been one of my favorite color
watch bands recently I also have the
iPhone case to match this is what your
Apple watch might look like after it
goes through the walk there's some
scratches on the front also some
scratches on the back but to be
completely honest with you this thing
survived a full cycle and the watch I'm
currently wearing this beautiful rose
gold aluminum watch face with one of the
new pink bands and a fisted focus it's
not focusing but you get the white I'm
going to put that back looks good looks
nice let's try it on it's beautiful the
only problem is I have a very tiny wrist
does go all the way to the top and I
have to make it a little bit looser
because it does hit right there that's
the black Milanese OOP mmm next up I
know I'm definitely gonna be keeping
this one as well it is the nylon pink
band I love it
ok so this is the nylon band gold royal
blue
so there's the nylon Gold / blue here's
the thing a lot of these I think colors
are color preferences of what you guys
actually like so what I like might not
be what you guys like so for me this one
I'm not a huge fan of this color
combination that's just me
it also looks a lot different on the box
it looks a lot more yellow actually
thought I was gonna like this one a lot
more let's check out the nylon band
pearl this does a little very white to
me I was expecting and it's like the
same color on the back as well so
there's really not much difference
between the pearl this looks a lot more
white nylon band gold red that's a
little bit.you let's see what the other
side looks like I'm confused it's not
this red gold most exactly it is it's
this it's the tada what the it's
literally the same it's the same thing
but it's flipped I don't like that okay
here's the black this looks good
I'm into this here's the inside here's
the outside flip flip flip there was a
royal blue and I think it was like a
blue gold one it which probably would
also would have been the same exact
thing
finally this all-out I can give you guys
a quick little look-see you can search
ones you guys might like to get or not
yet I know the sound does nothing can
see the world when it spinning spinning
compensating for the wish I could fly
like an airplane stop in everything
won't be breaking easily now
and update so as I was editing this
video I felt like I'm not being the
truthful with you guys because by the
time I edited this video and it's ready
to post
I had already returned most of the watch
bands that you guys have seen in this
video not a huge fan of the nylon bands
I much prefer the sport band so what I
did is returned most of the nylon bands
except for this really awesome pink one
I got the blue watch band with the blue
case to match and also the pink a it's
to match the pink watch band thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed this video let me know what your
favorite new watch band color is or what
your favorite watch band is overall or
if you don't even like the Apple watch
or if you want to get an Apple watch or
if you're waiting for the Apple watch to
which hopefully that won't be one
because I really do love my have a watch
I'll see you guys in the next video hope
you guys have an amazing week know like
you're gonna put this on you need him in
your sweatshirt okay
can you move my hair out okay thank you
okay we need a bigger sponsor